Johnson Virginia we paid off our car in
April and last week I hit a deer
totaling the car that got me the
insurance payout is 6500 and that won't
pay for a car that we are willing to
drive why the car you were driving on a
6500 why were you and willing to drive a
65 on another car should we fully
financed a new car and save the
settlement money or put it toward the
purchase price to reduce what we have to
finance John you're too stupid for me to
help seriously that's the dumbest thing
I've ever heard in my life you just you
just emailed Dave Ramsey and said how do
you finance a car and you knew what you
were doing that's just too dumb to help
it listen if you didn't get what your
car was worth out of your car you have a
case against the insurance company but
otherwise dude you're driving a $6,500
car so get you another $6,500 car and
quit your whining when call the
wambulance I don't like my $6,500 car
cuz a deer ran out in front of me way
well if you if your car is an 8500 ollar
car then you need to sue your insurance
company for $2,000 you shouldn't have
accepted the settlement but apparently
your car was a $6,500 car so go buy
another one until you have the money to
do that
should we fully finance a new car give
me a break seriously folks let me help
you with this all right the average car
payment in America today is 502 dollars
over 84 months according to the National
Auto Dealers Association $500 a month
invested from age 30 to age 70 is
between five and six million dollars in
your Roth IRA I hope you like your
stupid butt car that's just dumb you
could have retired with five or six
million dollars instead you're driving
something that's going down and valued
like a rock in calling yourself cool at
the stoplight to impress people you'll
never even meet
it's just nutty this car culture is
nutty and I'm a car guy I love cars I
drove a really nice Roush Ford down here
a while I got a 600 horsepower it's a
freaking beast I love cars but they all
go down in value like a rock if you want
to stay middle-class the rest of your
life I don't be mad at you but it's
stupid the best way state mental class
keep a car payment oh you're always
gonna have a car payment the little man
can't get ahead what is a or your spirit
animal seriously little man can't get
ahead I'm stuck my father I hope the
Camino Company I'm a victim you're not a
victim you're buying crap you can't
afford with money you don't have to
impress people that you don't even
really like you're not a victim of
anything except yourself I've been a
victim of myself so I know what that
looks like I've done so many stupid
things in my life and you know whose
fault it was stupid Dave and when smart
Dave took over and we didn't feed stupid
Dave along stupid Dave finally starved
out and I got tired of being broke yo so
I couldn't make it broke people
decisions like car payments car payments
are straight-up stupid and let me just
talk man it's amazing you read these
articles in these supposed financial
things this crap like was a CBS market
watch they are the Yahoo Finance and oh
god help you CNN money right you read
through there all of these journalism
students that are 27 years old with
student loans coming out their ears or
writing these articles for these finance
lines for these finance blogs or
whatever they are I came calling what
they're called but they're writing these
articles and they can't even do math but
they make the assumption you're always
gonna have a car payment so here's the
best way to have a car and you know for
people who can't afford it well you know
why you can't afford it because you got
payments that's why you can't afford it
that or you don't work and if you don't
work you don't need payments so if you
work and earn an income though I
those give all your money to somebody
else then scratch your dadgum head and
wonder why you're broke you're broke
because you were stupid because you gave
your money to somebody else to drive
something you couldn't afford to drive
it is that simple if you can't afford to
pay for it you can't afford to go on
vacation stupid if you can't write a
check and pay for that car you can't
afford that car it's costing you five or
six million dollars in the scope of your
life you could have retired with dignity
and changed your whole family tree and
driven anything you want to drive by the
way which is what I Drive now because I
lived this way for 20 years now in 30
years now coming up on 30 years I've
been doing this I mean I'm getting old
that's what makes me mean and angry like
that it's just I just I just have no
patience for this I mean what should I
do
take the money and put it in the bank
and get a car payment give me a break
not less you won't be broke the rest of
your life get away from car payments
that young couple called it a few
minutes ago that debt free scream you
know what they did they sold their
stupid cars and they got a beater now
let me ask you this are twenty eight
years old they're making $75,000 they
don't have any debt in the world how
long do you think they're gonna drive a
beater not long does if you don't have
any payments you know what you have
money
how many $500 a month for ten months and
you're a bank account
it's called $5,000 isn't it can you buy
a good car for $5,000 yeah 10 months
later could you buy a $10,000 car yeah
because your $5,000 car didn't go down
in value so if I was another car plus
$5,000 more in your account oh do it 10
more months now we're to $15,000 car
were 30 months and two and a half years
in of living Grandma's away and paying
cash for it out of that two and a half
years 10 months she drove a $5,000 car
10 months you drove a $10,000 car in 10
months you drove a well there's none of
the 10 months isn't it okay 10 much you
drove a $5,000 car yeah and
when she drove a $10,000 car and then
ten months you're driving a thirty
months you're driving a $15,000 car so
it's like well this is we're saying do
this forever but drive like no one else
so that later you can drive like no one
else make different decisions than broke
people make I mean make different
decisions if you want a great marriage
from people that are married and have a
great marriage and do what they do
you've been married 16 times I don't
need your advice on marriage you don't
know anything about marriage you know a
lot about honeymoons but you don't know
much about marriage I want to find
somebody's winning at whatever it is
they're doing if you want to grow hair
you don't need to ask me I'm not good at
it on top of my head okay it's not much
there so I can't help you with that if
you need to know about hair care
products I can't help you with that
mine is hand soap it's not you know I
don't have hair care products I haven't
seen a barber in a decade Sam's clippers
that's it right there number three right
there it's over you know it's I can't
help you with that if you need it if you
want to know about hair gel get somebody
that knows some hair know some about
hair gel but learn from somebody who's
winning for goodness sakes whatever it
is you're doing if you look around all
the brook people you know what they have
freaking car payments no plan and no
communication with their spouse I live
like that you get the decision you can
change you can decide to change you're
not a victim of anything except your
stupid but decisions that's the only
thing you're a victim of so make a
decision that's different I'm going to
decide to treat my spouse better I'm
going to decide to spend less than I
make a concept Congress can't grasp I'm
going to decide you can decide I'm going
to do a budget you can just decide
tonight ready ready set go ready set go
[Music]
you can do this you got this you can do
it there's no reason to be like all
those other people
you can do it hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]